Although we discussed an important today
in history moment yesterday, the June
28th Battle of Antioch, it's time for
another campaigning season, summertime
is here. So get ready for lots of these
today in history moments over the next 2
or 3 months. Okay, here we go. On June
29th in the year 1236, the city of
Cordoba, once the jewel of Muslim Spain
and a symbol of Islamic dominance in
Europe, was reclaimed by the Christian
forces of King Ferdinand or Fernando III
of Castile, a man later canonized as a
saint, not for piety alone, but as we
shall soon see, for acts of
extraordinary valor in the Crucible of
Holy War. Six months earlier, in
December of 1235, a daring band of
Christians, led by a few knights stormed
and took a portion of Cordoba's eastern
quarter. Word reached King Ferdinand in
January of 1236, even as he was in
mourning over the recent death of his
30-year-old wife from childbirth
complications. The messenger implored
him to come to the aid of the holdup and
vastly outnumbered Christians who were
separated from the Muslims, clamoring
for their blood by a thin wall. The
king, who for years had been
spearheading the reconista, the
Christian attempt to liberate Spain from
Islam, was heavily moved by such a
heroic feat. And the grief for the loss
of his wife did not long suspend his
warlike preparations, wrote a
chronicler. On the same evening that the
messenger arrived, Ferdinand's advisers
strongly warned him against setting out
now during winter. They cited impassible
roads due to snow, rain, and floods, and
possible ambushes from the innumerable
multitude of moors, they said. to say
nothing of Hud, the de facto king of
Elendelus, who was even then headed to
Cordoba. But Ferdinand quote placed his
hope in the Lord Jesus Christ and closed
his ears to all such talk, continues the
chronicler. He was resolved to aid his
vassels who had exposed themselves to
such a great danger in his service and
for the honor of the Christian faith.
After sending word to his magnates in
Castile and Lyon to muster their forces,
he set off for Cordoba on the very next
morning with only 100 knights. Despite
the terrible road conditions, the
35-year-old king rode furiously through
rain and sle and reached the great
Murish city on February 7th. Ibn Hood
had arrived before him with a much
greater force, reportedly 35,000 Moors.
But instead of waiting and meeting the
Castilians, and perhaps because they had
soundly defeated him a few years earlier
at the battle of JZ in 1231, he
unexpectedly withdrew back to Sevel. As
might be expected, the holdup Christians
burst in joy and seeing their king. This
man who quote had exposed himself to
much danger so that he could sucker his
people, continues the chronicler. After
rescuing the daring band of Christians,
Ferdinand laid siege to Cordoba. As
Christian fighters continued to pour in
from Lyon, Castile and Galissia, the
news tightened around the Muslim city.
Five months later, on today's date, June
29th, 1236, Cordoba. For centuries, the
ornament of the world, the ancient seat
of Umiad Khalifs, and of course, the
Islamic world's chief emporium for white
Christian slaves surrendered to
Ferdinand. Everyone had something to say
about this grand event. Al- Makari, the
normally objective Arab historian,
captured Muslim sentiment by bemoning
how, quote, "that seat of the Western
Caliphate, repository of the Muslim
sciences, an abode of Islam, passed into
the hands of the Christians, may Allah
destroy them all." For the indigenous
Christians of Spain, however, the
conquest, as with all conquests of the
reconista, was the mere writing of a
wrong. As the Latin chronicle relays,
quote, "The famous city of Cordoba,
endowed with certain splendor and rich
soil, which had been held captive for
such a long time, that is from the time
of Rodrigo, the king of the Goths, who
was killed in 7-eleven at the battle of
Guadalete during the initial invasion of
Spain, was restored to the Christian
faith by the labor and valor of our
king, Lord Ferdinand." Ferdinand granted
lenient terms. Those Muslims who wanted
to leave with all their movable
possessions were provided safe passage.
Those who wish to remain and practice
the religion could do so. Either way,
Ferdinand proceeded to repopulate
Cordoba with quote new inhabitants,
followers of Christ. Before entering and
claiming kingship of Cordoba, Ferdinand
ordered that the standard of the cross
be carried before his own standard and
placed on the highest minret of the
largest mosque. an event that quote
caused ineffable confusion and
lamentation among the sarissens and on
the other hand ineffable joy among the
Christians. Next, the great mosque of
Cordoba which Abdul Rahman I a highly
celebrated khalif among western
academics built in the 8th century after
he had demolished and cannibalized the
materials of St. Vincence, an important
6th century Visigoththic church, was
quote cleansed of all filthiness of
Muhammad, the Archbishop of Toledo
wrote, and sprinkled with holy water and
salt so that what had once been the
devil's layer was made a church of
Jesus.
As I was saying, the Archbishop of
Toledo wrote about how the church or the
mosque was sprinkled with holy water and
salt so that quote, "What had once been
the devil's lair was made a church of
Jesus Christ end quote." Finally,
Ferdinand found the bells of St. James
Madamoras, the Moore Slayer. They had
been seized 250 years earlier by Muslim
jihadists and sent to Cordoba on the
backs of Christian slaves to adorn
Cordoba's great mosque as trophies of
war. Writing this ancient wrong, the
king, who was well acquainted with the
details of Muslim Christian history, had
them returned to the shrine of Santiago,
carried a top the backs of captive
Muslim fighters, no less. Such was the
reconquest of Cordoba, one of
Christendom's greatest victories over
Islam. And it occurred on this day in
history.